Ends Monday.
To learn more, go to
sleepnumber.com
Ends Monday.
JEDEDIAH: NEW YORK GOVERNOR
ANDREW CUOMO BRUSHING OFF
CRITICISM NURSING HOME DEATHS
DUE TO COVID-19.
>> IT’S ALL POLITICS.
THEY WANT TO ATTACK THE
DEMOCRATS FOR NURSING HOME
DEATHS.
IT’S THE SAME M.O., JUST
DISTRACT.
YOU KNOW, CREATE A SHINY OBJECT
TO TAKE ATTENTION OFF WHAT THEY
DON’T WANT YOU TO FOCUS ON.
JEDEDIAH: SOME SAY THE NUMBERS
SHOW IT’S NOT ABOUT POLITICS AS
DEATHS IN NURSING HOMES ACCOUNT
FOR 26% OF ALL CORONAVIRUS
DEATHS IN THE STATE.
JOINING ME NOW TO DISCUSS FOX
NEWS MEDICAL CONTRIBUTOR AND
AUTHOR OF "MAKE AMERICA HEALTHY
AGAIN" A FANTASTIC BOOK YOU
SHOULD ALL CHECK OUT, DR. NICOLE
SAPHIER.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW AS ALWAYS.
SO, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF CUOMO’S
COMMENTS HERE?
IT’S PRETTY OUTRAGEOUS.
BUT, FROM WHERE I’M SIGNATURES,
FOR HIM TO JUST SAY THIS IS ALL
POLITICAL, IT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH ME AND MY DECISION-MAKING
AND POINT THE BLAME ELSEWHERE.
>> WELL, JEDEDIAH, I THINK IT’S
ACTUALLY QUITE COMICAL THAT A
POLITICIAN IS SAYING IT’S ALL
POLITICAL.
FIRST OF ALL OUR OWN JANIS DEAN
HAS BEEN ONE OF THE MOST VOCALLY
PRESENT IN THIS MATTER.
SHE DOESN’T HAVE A POLITICAL
BONE IN HER BODY.
SO IT IS EXTREMELY INFLAMMATORY
FOR PRESIDENT CUOMO -- GOVERNOR
CUOMO TO SAY THAT.
THIS HIGHLIGHTS A IMPORTANT
POINT WE HAVE IN THE UNITED
STATES.
THAT IS OUR NURSING HOME CARE.
WE HAVE SEEN OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
EVERY TIME A HURRICANE OR
NATURAL DISASTER IS HIT.
THE NURSING HOMES HAVE SUFFERED
AND REALLY STRUGGLED TO KEEP
THEIR PATIENTS SAFE.
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
COVID-19 THIS IS AL HIGHLY
TRANSMISSIBLE VIRUS.
THIS POPULATION IN PARTICULAR IS
EXTREMELY SUSCEPTIBLE TO SEVERE
EFFECTS OF THIS VIRUS.
SO, IN MARCH, ORDERS WENT OUT
SAYING THAT NURSING HOMES HAD IN
FACT TO TAKE COVID POSITIVE
PATIENTS BACK INTO THE NURSING
HOMES.
THAT CREATED MANY ISSUES.
OF THE FEDERAL GUIDELINES ARE
HAVING THIS TIT-FOR-TAT RIGHT
NOW.
CUOMO SAYING HE WAS FOLLOWING
FEDERAL GUIDELINES AND SEEMA
VERMA SAID NO, YOU DIDN’T.
FEDERAL GUIDELINES SAID NURSING
HOMES HAD TO TAKE THEM BACK IF
THEY WERE PREPARED AND ABLE TO
CARE FOR THOSE PATIENTS.
THAT’S A VERY BIG CAVEAT.
MEANING YOU NEEDED TO HAVE THE
STAFFING.
THEY NEEDED TO HAVE THE PPE.
AND THEY REALLY NEEDED A
STEPDOWN UNIT OR AREA WHERE JUST
THOSE COVID POSITIVE PATIENTS
WERE.
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS VIRUS, IT
IS HIGHLY TRANSMISSIBLE.
VERY HIGH R NOT MEANING IT’S
VERY CONTAGIOUS IN THE ELDERLY
THEY TEND TO HAVE VIRAL SHEDDING
LONGER THAN THE REST OF THE
POPULATION.
SO THEY STAY INFECTIOUS LONGER
THAN SAY MAYBE YOU AND I AUTO
WOULD, JEDEDIAH.
THAT’S ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PROBLEMS HERE.
JEDEDIAH: THE ONE THING, I MEAN
THAT WE KNEW FROM THE BEGINNING
THAT SEEMED TO BE CONSISTENT
WHEN SO MANY OTHER THINGS WITH
RESPECT TO THIS VIRUS WAS NOT
CONSISTENT THERE WAS A
VULNERABLE POPULATION PEOPLE WHO
WERE OLDER WERE MORE SUCCESS 2E7
SUSCEPTIBLE.
I DON’T KNOW IF YOU CAN WEIGH IN
ON THIS.
NURSING HOMES ARRANGED THE
COUNTRY DIDN’T NECESSARILY HAVE
THIS PROBLEM.
THERE WERE A LOT OF NURSING
HOMES IN OTHER STATES THAT WERE
ABLE TO PROTECT THEIR PATIENTS.
SO FOR CUOMO TO TURN AROUND AND
SAY THIS IS ALL ABOUT TRUMP.
THIS IS BAWL DIRECTIVES FROM THE
CDC.
THOSE DIRECTIVES WERE CONSISTENT
EVERYWHERE.
THAT’S NOT WHAT HAPPENED IN NEW
YORK.
>> WELL, THERE IS A DIFFERENCE
THOUGH, I HAVE TO SAY, JEDEDIAH,
WHEN IT COMES TO THE NORTHEAST
VEST SUCCESS THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY.
TOUGH REMEMBER WE HAD
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE CASES IN THE
BEGINNING.
I CAN TELL FROM YOU PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE, OUR HOSPITAL SYSTEMS
WERE OVERFLOWING WITH COVID
PATIENTS.
THERE WAS NO WAY, SHAPE, OR FORM
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO KEEP ALL THOSE PATIENTS IN
THE HOSPITAL.
ESPECIALLY IF THEY ONLY HAD MILD
INFECTIONS AT THAT TIME.
SO IT WAS NECESSARY TO GET SOME
OF THOSE PATIENTS THAT DIDN’T
REQUIRE IN PATIENT
HOSPITALIZATION OUT OF THE
HOSPITAL.
IT’S ALSO GOOD FOR THEIR SAFETY
AS WELL BECAUSE KEEPING PEOPLE
IN THE HOSPITAL FOR LONG PERIODS
OF TIME.
THAT BEING SAID, JEDEDIAH, WITH
THAT DIRECTIVE, KNOWING THAT
THEY NEEDED TO GET THE ELDERLY
OUT OF THE HOSPITAL INTO NURSING
HOMES, THEY NEEDED TO MAKE A
PRIORITY THAT THOSE NURSING
HOMES COULD CARE FOR THOSE
PATIENTS AND THAT IS WHAT DID
NOT HAPPEN.
JEDEDIAH: YEAH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, NICOLE.
FOR YOUR -- PERHAPS USE A
COMFORT SHIP OR ANOTHER VEHICLE
OR MECHANISM THAT DIDN’T INVOLVE
THE MOST VULNERABLE POPULATION
WHICH EVERYONE WAS SAYING
PROTECT THE ELDERLY.
PEOPLE OVER A CERTAIN AGE ARE
MORE AT RISK FOR SERIOUS
INFECTION.
MADNESS, AND IF NOTHING ELSE HE